[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم عبد القادر عياد في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث تتفاعل اخرى في
مناطق مختلفه من العالم البدايه من واشنطن
حيث اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض
عقوبات على المؤسسه التعاونيه للحرس
الثوريه الايراني
ثم الى العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت واجواء ما
بعد اعلان المحقق العدلي استئناف تحقيقه
في انفجار مرفاي بيروت بعد 13 شهرا على
تعليقه
وجراء دعوى رفعها ضده طباعا عدد من المدعي
عليه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في تحرك المنسق عقوبات متزامنه امريكيه
واوروبيه وبريطانيه على ايران تستهدف
افرادا وكيانات وتشمل تجميد اصول وحظرا
للسفر واشنطن تقول ان عقوبتها تستهدف
ركيزه الاقتصاديه الرئيسيه للحرس الثوري
لندن تعتبر عقوباتها رساله واضحه تتعلق
بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان والاتحاد الاوروبي
يستثل حرس الثوري ويحط طاهره على وقف ما
سماها حمله القمع
تصاعد المعارك شرقيه اوكرانيا كيف تصفها
بالحاسمه والصعبه وتؤكد ان القوات الروسيه
تعد تجميع صفوفها في جمباز بولندا تقول
انها تخطط لارسال دبابات اليوبارد الى
اوكرانيا حتى دون موافقه برلين الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعد لعاشر حزمه عقوبات على روسيا
وسابع دفعه مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا
بعد توقف لاكثر من عام للتحقيقات في
انفجار بيروت المحقق كونان
الدعاء على ثمانيه اشخاص بينهم مسؤولان
امنيان رفيع المستوى وزير العدل في حكومه
تصريف الاعمال يعلن احاله القرار الى مجلس
القضاء الاعلى للتاكد من حسن سير العداله
في ضغط على المحكمه الاسرائيليه العليا
لازاله منازل الفلسطينيين في الخان الاحمر
شرقي القدس
[موسيقى]
اعضاء في الكنيست من اللكود يتجمعون عند
الخام لحاث الحكومه على الاسرار في تنفيذ
قرار الهدم ومفوض السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر من خطوره الوضع
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقم يكون قد ناقشنا معكم تجمع اعضاء في
حزبود ومستوطنين واعضاء منظمات يهوديه
متطرفه عند مشارف في الخادم الاحمر شرقي
القدس وقضى المشاركون في التجمع انه يندرج
في اطار الضغوط على حكومه
لكي تسرع في تنفيذ قرار هدم التجمع
وازالته يشار الى ان محكمه العدل العليا
الاسرائيليه ستنظر مطلعه الشهر المقبل في
طلب منظمه الرياضيهم الصهيونيه اتخاذ قرار
نهائي من شان تنفيذي عمليه الهضمي ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي لماذا قد تمضي حكومه في
قرار الهدم 25 في المئه رجعه مضي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في خطه الهدم مجاره لحلفائها
المتشددين وقال تمارين واربعون في المئه
انها قد تفعل ذلك لاظهار صرامه تجاه
ودها بس 27% الى انها قد تمضي في الهدم
استباقا لقرار محكمه العليا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصهنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقاؤنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيه
ودوليه
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
رغم احتجاجات هي اضخم في فرنسا خلال عقدين
الحكومه الفرنسيه تتمسك بخطط مثيره للجدل
لتعديل نظام التقاعد
[موسيقى]
قالت الرئاسه السويديه للاتحاد الاوروبي
ان وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد اقر حزمه جديده
من العقوبات على ايران واضافت في تغريده
ان العقوبات على ايران تستهدف من يقودون
القمع على حد تعبيرها واوضحت الرئاسه
السويديه ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه بقوه
ما سمته لاستخدام الوحشي وغير المتناسب
للقوه من جانب السلطات الايرانيه في
مواجهه المتظاهرين السلبيين وقالت المصادر
لرويترز ان وزراء خارجيه التكتل سيضيفون
سبعه
لقائمه الاتحاد الاوروبي للافراد
والكيانات الخاضعين لعقوبات بسبب انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان في ايران
هذا وقال بيان الاوروبي ان العقوبات
الجديده ضد الافراد والكيانات الايرانيه
تشمل تجميد الاصول وحضر سفر الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وحظر اتاحه الاموال لمن هم
مدرجون في القائمه كما تم فرض حظر على
تصدير المعدات الى ايران والتي يمكن
استخدامها للقمع الداخلي ومعدات مراقبه
الاتصالات وحتى الاتحاد الاوروبي السلطات
الايرانيه على وقف ما وصفها بحمله القمع
العنيفه ضد الاحتجاجات السلمي
هذا وقال مفاوض السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان ارى اعضاء الاتحاد
متباينه بشان وضع الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه العقوبات الاوروبيه وانه يجب
دراسه الامر قبل اتخاذ قرار مشيرا الى انه
لا يمكن تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه
من دون وجود حكم قضائي
المتباينه لكن لا يمكن اتخاذ قرار دون حكم
محكمه عندما تاخذ محكمه في احدى الدول
الاعضاء قرارا بشان ذلك وتصدر اذانه واضحه
حينها يمكننا العمل على المستوى الاوروبي
لكن قبل هذا كله كما قلت يتطلب الامر حكم
قضائيا
وفي واشنطن اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
عقوبات شملت المؤسسه التعاونيه للحرس
الثوري الايراني وخمسه اعضاء من مجلس
ادارتها بالاضافه الى نائب وزير
الاستخبارات والامن واربعه من كبار قاده
الحرس الثوري في ايران وافادت الوزاره في
بيان ان الاجراء الذي تم بالتنسيق مع
بريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي يستهدف ركيزه
الاقتصاديه رئيسيه للحرس الثوري الايراني
معتبره انها تمول من القمع الوحشي
لاحتجاجات على حد تعبيريان وقال مساعد
وزيره الخزانه ان بلاده تظلم ملتزمتا بدعم
الشعب الايراني في مطالبه بحقوق الانسان
والحريات الاساسيه مشددا على انها ستواصل
العمل مع شركائها لمحاسبه النظام الايراني
على العوف والمحاكمات الصوريه واعدام
المتظاهرين واساليب القمع الاخرى حسب نص
البيان انا
ومن جانبها قالت او اعلنت بريطانيا اليوم
حزمه جديده من العقوبات على مسؤولين
ايرانيين ونددت بما سمته العنف الذي
تمارسه سلطات البلاد ضد شعبها بما في ذلك
اعدام المواطن البريطانيه الايراني علي
رضا اكبر وتشمل العقوبات البريطانيه
الجديده تجميده اصول وحظر صفر على عدد من
المسؤولين بمن فيهم نائب المدعي العام
الايراني احمد فاضل ايام وقال وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر لي في بيان
ان من صدرت عقوبات بحقهم اليوم شخصيات
قضائيه تستغل عقوبه الاعدام لاغراض سياسيه
وافراد عصابات يعتدون بالضرب على المحتجين
في الشوارع
المقابل دعى وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الله ايام الدول الاوروبيه كافه
للابتعاد عن ما وصفها بالمواقف غير البنا
وغير المنطقيه والا تتخذ خطوات يمكن ان
تكون لها تداعيات جسيمه وفقه تعبيره واضاف
الوزير الايراني انه في حال اتخاذ الدول
الاوروبيه قرارا ضد مؤسسه سياديه مثل حرس
الثوري ستشهد ردا قويا ومؤثرا من جانب
طهران حسب تعذيره
عزف حدود الدومه
منذ شهرين التدخلات من جانب الدول الغربيه
في شؤوننا الداخليه واستغلال الوضع في
ايران وحذرنا الدول الاوروبيه بشكل جدي
انه في حاله اتخذت قرارا ضد مؤسسه
انسياديه مثل الحرس الثوري فسيكون ردنا
بالمقابل قويا ومؤثرا قرار البرلمان
الاوروبي الاخير بشان الحرس الثوري
الايراني متسرع وغير منطقي وعاطفي ويتعارض
مع القوانين والاعراف الدوليه اكدت خلال
اتصالات مع المسؤولين الاوروبيين ان عليهم
الابتعاد عن المواقف غير البناء وغير
المنطقيه بشان ايران وان لا تتخذ بلدانهم
خطوات يمكن ان تكون لها تداعيات جسيمه
من مدينه ليدز في انجلترا الدكتور علم
صالح استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق الاوسط في
الجامعه الوطنيه
الاسطراليه دكتور كيف وجدت هذه الحزمه من
العقوبات تقول واشنطن بانها تمت بالتنسيق
بينها وبين لندن والاتحاد الاوروبي
بصوره خاصه تعاني من العقوبات منذ عقود
فاذا همم لا شيء جديد من من جانب الضغط
حول النشاطات الحرس الثوري في داخل في
داخل ايران ام خارجها همم وهذه همم
التصرفات الجديده للامارات من قبل
الاوروبيين همم لا تجني الاوروبيين شيئا
ولا يضر الحرس الثوري ولا طهران بصوره
عامه همم ولكن هنالك
مقاطعه دكتور علم تقول بان هذه الحزمه
الجديده تمس بشكل اساسي مؤسسه رئيسيه في
ما تقول بانه تمول مؤسسه الحرس الوطني او
الحرس الثوري في ايران
النشاطات ال ال الخارجيه للحرس الثوري
نشاطات سريه كانت منذ عقود والى يومنا هذا
فلذلك اي عقوبات رسميه من قبل اي دول لا
لا تزيد ولا ولا تنقص عنها شيء
ولكن بالنسبه للنشاطات الداخليه فاذا
العقوبات لا ايضا ايضا لا تجدي شيئا
الاوروبيين
لديها حوريات مطلقه في داخل ايران ولكن
بسرعه ايضا لا ننسانا لا استثمارات من قبل
الحرس الثوري في اوروبا او دول الغربيه
بصوره عامه فلذلك اي عقوبات جديده هي ليست
الا رمزيه وشكليه وان دل على شيء انما يدل
على ان خطاب جديد من قبل الاوروبيين همم
سيحصل ولها تداعيات الثلاثه اولا
المفاوضات النوويه لان نحن كنا قريبين جدا
همم للوصول نتائج ايجابيه حولها همم تؤثر
عليها سلبيا لان الاوروبيين كانت دور وسيط
همم وثانيا ان تزيد التوترات في منطقه
الخليج بصوره عامه لان ايضا ال- ال- طهران
راح تصنف الجهات الاوروبيه في المنطقه همم
كجهات ارهابيه وثالثا تقوي دور الحرس
الثوري في الداخلي ايران ضد الجهات
الفكريه ال- ال- المعتدله والاصلاحيه
في هذه الحاله كلام وزير الخارج الايراني
كان واضحه من اي قرارات تستهدف مؤسسه
سياديه كما قال تستدعي ردا ايرانيا هذه
الحزمه هل تتوقع ان يكون لها رد كما قال
وزير خارج سيكون ردا قويه
الاشكال نيران
تصنف الجهات الغربيه
القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه قوات ارهابيه
تصنف الجهات الاوروبيه الان كقوات ارهابيه
وهذا يصعد التوتر
واحتمال المواجهه العسكريه بين الاثنين او
طرفان فلذلك هذا الامر ليس امر ايجابي وان
دل على شيء ما يدل على انها سياسيه همم
وتذكرنا ب 2002 و2003 عندما المشروع
الغربي ضد العراق همم بنيت حول العلاقه
العراقيه مع الارهابيين وال اسلحه الدمار
الشامل هذه الحجاج الكاذبه اللي همم انتجت
الى حرب العراق وكوارث شاهدناها من دعاه
لي الان نرى ان هذه الحجاج همم تاتي كخطاب
سياسي من الاوروبا ك- ربط ايران بقضيه
الارهاب وثانيا قضيه السلاحها السلاح
الدبا الدمار الشامل ايضا وهذا ربما تكون
مشروع
لعراقيه القضيه الايرانيه اليوم من ليدز
في انجلترا دكتور عالم صالح استاذ دراسات
ايران والشرق الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه
استراليا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا جبهات
الشرق تشتعل القوات الاخرانيه تصف المعارك
في دومباس بالحاسمه وتقول انها صعبه
تتزامن هذه المعارك مع قصف روسي كثير على
زفه
وبموازته ذوي المدافع يتفجر استجلال اخر
مع اتهام موسكو لكيف بتخزينه اسلحه ثقيله
داخله محطات نوويه
بعد مرور 11 شهرا على بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا لا تزال موسكو تحاولوا فرض
سيطرتها بالكامل على اقليم ادومباز اذ
يسعى الجيش الروسي مسنودا بمليشيا فاكنار
والقوات الانفصاليه المواليه له الى تحقيق
تقدم حاسم على جبهات الاقليم الساخنه خلال
الاسابيع المتبقيه من فصل الشتاء في محور
باخ موتو استراتيجي غربيه حيث لا تهدا
المعارك تقول القوات المواليه لروسيا انها
نجحت بالسيطره على بلدتين جديدتين هناك
القوات الاوكرانيه من جانبها تقول انها
خاضت ما سمتها معارك حساسه في بلده اوبنه
جنوب الشرقيه
واستهدفت قوات روسيه على تلك الجبهات
في حين هزت سلسله انفجارات جراء قصف روسي
عده مدن واقعه تحت سيطره سلطات كياف غربيه
وجنوبا جونيورز ابرزها اكرام تورسك ودروس
كيفك
بموازاه التطورات في اقليم دوم بس افادت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه باجتداد القصف
الروسي على المناطق الماهوله بالسكان في
مقاطعه خرسون وزابولوجيا جنوب شرقي البلاد
بحسب الهيئه فان اكثر من 20 بلده في
زبرجها تعرضت لقصف المدفعي خلال ساعات
الماضيه
القصف الروسي استهدف كذلك قرا واقعه على
خط التماس في مقاطعه خرسون
لكن هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اكدت في
المقابل نجاحها بتكبير القوات الروسيه
خسائر في كلتا المقاطعتين
وسياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيه بريل انه جرى التوصل لاتفاق السياسي
على تقديم حزمه سابعه من الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا واضاف بريل من الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيواصل دعمك لانها يجب ان تنتصر في الحرب
حسب قوله وجاء التصريحات بوريل في مؤتمر
صحفي اعقب اجتماعا للوزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي لبحث فرض حزمه عاشره من العقوبات
واستخدام اصول روسيه مصادره لاعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا
انا كنت قد اجريت مقابله مع وزيره
الخارجيه البلجيكيه حاجه لحبيب وسالتها
اولا عن نتائج اجتماع اليوم في ظلي تباين
بين الدول الاوروبيه تجاه الموقفين من
روسيا
60 ثانيه
وبدانا بافضل الثمانينات للعام المقبل
وهذا ما سمعنا اليه من قبل الاعضاء يجب
علينا ان نتوحد اكثر من ذي قبل في مواجهه
التحديات والحرب في اوكرانيا
الزميل
بالنسبه الى الاختلافات في وجهه النظر
التي ظهرت في وسائل الاعلام بنسبه الى
تقديم الاسلحه الثقيله الى اوكرانيا يجب
ان نعرف ان الوزيره اوضحت الوزيره المانيه
اوضحت انه ما من طلب تقدم الى المانيا
واذا ما من مشكله ما من اختلافات بالنسبه
الى الدول 27 قررنا بالاجماع بان انه يقدم
5 مليون يورو اللي همم
تيسير عملياتي الاوروبيه للسلام لمساعدتي
اوكرانيا باشارته لوزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ومسرحتي فيما يتعلق بالدبابات
الالمانيه هناك من يقول هذا همم ما قالته
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ليس بالضروره ما
تقوله المستشاريه في المانيا قد يكون لها
موقف مختلف ولكن الاختلاف اعمق بين ربما
دولتين بحجم فرنسا والمانيا فيما يتعلق
بالتعاطي مع موضوع الحرف اقرا وبالتالي
كيف تعاملت مع هذه الاشكالات والخلافات
داخل الاتحاد
مسلسل
الصراحه لم يكن هناك اختلافات تم التعبير
عنها بين الدول ال 27
بالاجماع على ال 500 مليون يورو لمساعدتي
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى حزمه عقبات جديده
اتجاه روسيا بنسبه الى موضوع الافريقي
والساحل نحن عرفنا ايضا انه من المهم
بالنسبه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يكون
هناك وبالتالي ما من اختلافات هل ستفردون
حزمه عقوبات جديده على روسيا كانت هناك
دعوات من قبل مسؤولين في الاتحاد وهنا
اعلي ما قاله الشاعر بالدعوه الى تجميد
اصول اموال البنك المركزي الروسيه المجمده
لدى دول الاتحاد هل هذا الموضوع طرح هذا
الاجتماع
نونا
بوبايه
بشكل مباشر الى مساله العقبه الجديده ولكن
طبعا بنسبه الى موضوع تجميدي
الاصول بلجيكا قامت بتجميد
الاصول لاننا في وسط نظام اوروكلير الذي
يسمح بانتقال الاموال لدينا 50 مليار من
الاصول المجمده للاوليغاريين ومئتين مليار
من المداولات عبر يورك لير وهو نظام في
بلجيكا مقره في بلجيكا اذا السؤال هو
كيفيه فك التجنيد عن هذه الاصول لدينا
حاجه الى اطار قانوني غير قائم حاليا
وبالتالي ولو كانت الفكره جذابه بان
نستخدم بعض الاموال لاعاده بناء اوكرانيا
هذا لم يتم طرق اليه على مستوى جدول
الاعمال بسبب غياب الاطار القانوني لذلك
حتى اذهب بشكل افضل ااه سيد الحبيب هل
تناولتم في هذا الاجتماع فقط ما تعلق
بالحزم التسعه للعقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا ام تناولتم ايضا عقوبات جديده
الاعمال استمعنا الى وزير الخارجيه
الاخرانيه في البدايه طبعا والذي طالب
بمساعدات عسكريه في الميدان وتطرقنا الى
خطه السلام من 10 نقاط التي اقترحها
الرئيس
الى النقطه الاولى اليوم صباحا في خلال
مع سيدروس
وتطرقنا الى وجودي همم
اوكرانيا في همم وفي همم وبالتالي اهميه
الحفاظ على سلامته وامني المحطات النوويه
وايضا التامين حصولي اوكرانيا على الطاقه
التي هي بحاجه اليها وبالتالي لم نتحدث عن
عقوبات جديده تطرقنا الى هذه النقاط التي
اشرت اليها بالاضافه الى الحديث عن محكمه
خاصه
النظري بالاعتداء الروسي هذه هي النقاط
التي كانت على جدول الاعمال باشارته
لموضوع الطاقه بعض المراقبين يقولون همم
اوروبا عقب قيام روسيا بالحرب على
اوكرانيا ربما فاجات حتى الرئيس الروسي
بهذا الموقف الموحد من قبل اوروبا ولكن مع
امتداد زمان الحرب بدا التظهر الخلافات
داخل دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في جمله
موضوعات منها موضوع الطاقه
التضخم حتى الجانب العسكري وربما ان طالت
الحرب اكثر فربما سوف تختلف حسابات اوروبا
ماذا عن هذه الاختلافات والتعامل معها في
حال ما طاله الحرب اكثر
منه
استراتيجيه بعيده الامل نحن نتحدث عن
اعاده البناء الان ولو ان الحرب مستمر
بقوه في الميدان نتحدث بناء البناء
التحتيه الحيويه التي تسمح لاوكرانيا
بالمقاومه نحن نتحدث عن محاربه الفلات من
العقاب وبلجيكا تتصرف في هذا المجال امام
المحكمه العدل الدوليه ولقد ايضا شاركنا
بعمليه جمع الادله التي جرت في مسرح
الجريمه نحن ليس لدينا انقسام في الموقف
انتم تشرون الى هذا السؤال بشكل متكرر
ولكن اسره على اجابه طبعا هناك بعض
الاختلافات في او تنوع في مواجهه النظر
نحن نتحدث عن 27 الدوله لا يمكننا ان نقار
اسبانيا اليوم على سبيل المثال بواقع
المجر او فنلندا المجر على سبيل المثال
التي تعتمد بشكل كبير على الطاقه وعلى
اتفاقات التي ابرمتها مع روسيا طبعا
الاوضاع في البلدان تختلف ولكن في نهايه
المطاف نتفق وهذه هي النقطه المهمه سيد
الحبيب ماذا عن بعض الاصوات حتى في داخل
اوروبا التي تقول بان حتى الان ومعاني
امتداد الحرب من يستفيد بشكل اكبر من هذه
الحرب هي
واشنطن ومن يخسر بشكل اكبر مع امتداد
الحرب هي الدول الاوروبيه خاصه الاقتصاديه
السجن
الى اي جهال لا الى اوروبا ولا الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث انها تؤدي
الى اختلالي توازن على المستوى العالمي
وتؤدي الى نشر الذعر وايضا خطر المجاعه
بنسبه الى دول افريقيا وخطر على امن
الطاقه وهي لا تخدم طبعا الشعب الروسي
الذي يعيش تحت نظام الديكتاتوري ولا يمكنه
ان يعبر عن رايه لذلك نحن على المستوى
البلجيكي نحن اااه حافظنا على التاشيرات
الانسانيه للسماح للروس الذين لا يتشاركون
نفس الراي مع الكريم ولا وجوهات النظر
الخاصه بالنظام في موسكو لكي يعبر عن وجهه
نظرهم شكرا
حبيب وزيره الخارجيه البلجيكيه
[موسيقى]
ومن جنوب افريقيا قال وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه
لم تعد هجين بل باتت شبهه حقيقيه جاء ذلك
في مؤتمر صحفي خلال اجتماع مع نظيرته
الجنوب افريقيه خلال زيارته لبريتوريا
واضاف لافروب ان بلاده ليست ضد الوساطه
بشان اوكرانيا ولكن كيف ليست مهتمه
بالمفاوضات بدفع من الغرب على حد وصفه
وقال انه كلما طال امد الازمه الاوكرانيه
زادت صعوبه الوصول الى حل
في مياه جنوب افريقيا مناورات بحريه روسيه
صينيه جنوب افريقيه فما اهدافه تدريبات
بمناسبه الذكرى الاولى لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا لكنها تبعد الاف الكيلومترات عن
مسرحها الحالي نبحث عن اجابه في فقره
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان حيث استانف المحقق العدلي في
قضيه انفجار بيروت القاضي طارق البيطار
تحقيقاته في ملف الانفجار وقرر اخلاء سبيل
خمسه موقفين والادعاء على ثمانيه اشخاص
بينهم مسؤوليه
وارتكز البيطار على اجتهاد القضائي للعوده
الى ممارسه مهامه بعد ما كانت محكمه
الاستئناف قررت في اكتوبر ترشيد الاول عام
2021 وقفه عن متابعه التحقيق في الملف
وضغطتان عاد لما فعلها المحقق العدلي في
قضيه انفجار مرفوع بيروت ولماذا الان
يسند القاضي طارق البيطار قرار عودته
لمزاوله مهامه الى اجتهاد قضائي ودراسه
قانونيه
بهما يتجاوز قرار محكمه الاستئناف الذي
اوقفه اواخر عام 2021 عن متابعه التحقيق
ونواب سابقون بحق القاضي البيطار بتهمه
الارتياب المشروع في مسار التحقيقات
ويتاكد من حسن سير العداله
والان العداله هي المطلب الاساس الباحث عن
من يبيه فثم تمي تجاوز السجالات التي
طالما حاطت عمل القاضي طارق البيطار ليسال
عما يمكن الاستئناف التحقيقات المجمده منذ
اكثر من عام ان يحققه الان
لا يضيع المحقق كونان
كيف ستتعامل النيابه العامه التميزيه مع
تلك القرارات وهي المناط بها تنفيذ
الاستدعاء واخلاء السبيل على حد سواء وكيف
تكون ردت فعل الاطراف السياسيه المطالبه
في الاساس بكف يد البيطار عن الملف بدعوه
السيسي اياه
المعروف ان القاضي البيطار سعى لاستجواب
عدد من كبار السياسه بل اصدر قبلا مذكره
توقيف بحق وزير المال السابق علي حسن خليل
لكن المذكره لم تنفذها القوه الامنيه
كما ادعي على وزير الاشغال السابق
لكنهما مثل اخرين نفي ارتكاب اي مخالفات
وقال ان البيطار لا يمتلك صلاحيه استجوا
بهما بنظر لتمتعهما بالحصانه
ذكر جدلون سيتجدد لا ريب مع استئناف
التحقيقات في حادثه المرفا المروعه بنسبه
لكثير من اهالي ضحايا انفجار المرفق يشكل
ذاك الاستئناف كما قالوا النبا الاكثر
ايجابيا في القضيه حتى الان
ارحب بضيفيه من بيروت اسعد بشاره الكاتب
الصحفي وامن بيروت وسير الزي ال كاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم
هذه العوده من قبل السيد طارق البيطار
الاستئناف في
تحقيق في هذه القضيه والشروع في استدعاء
اسماء ثقيله خاصه على الصعيد الامني
اولا تحيه لحضرتك اهلا وسهلا عبد القادر
وللاستاذ اسعد بشاره ولمشاهدين الجزيره
واضح تماما ان هذا القرار شكل مفاجاه
كبيره غير مسبوقه بتاريخ الحياه القضائيه
اللبنانيه ومعروف ان الاجتهاد الذي سار به
المحقق العدل استند الى وقائع هو اختارها
وهو اعتمدها دون ان يستشير اي هيئه قضائيه
معنيه وتاخر سنه وثلاثه اشهر بالوصول الى
هذا الاجتهاد وهنا نسال عن حق المعتقلين
المظلومين الذين هم ضحايا كما كذلك اهالي
ضحايا المرفا وبالتالي هذه الخطوه عادت
اشعال هذه القضيه الاشكاليه اصلا بالبلد
وواضح تماما ان المحقق العدل ست- استفاد
من لحظه
فيها البلد تحلل السلطات الدستوريه كلها
وانقسامات سياسيه عموديه وشعور بموقع
الرئاسي ولاحظه نضوج لعوامل تتداخل في هذه
اللحظه وتشي كان البلد يؤخذ نحو توترات
محسوبي بدقه وهذا ما يدفعني
بشاره ما الذي استدعمنا نحقق البيضار الذي
اختلف حتى يعود ويستانف التحقيق في هذا
الملف
مساء الخير لكم الدكتور وسيم بزي
وللمجاهدين الكرام الحقيقه اول ما ورد على
بالنسبه لي عندما علمنا باستئناف القاضي
طارق البيطار لما همته بقرار وليس باجتهاد
بنصوص قانونيه اول ما ورد هو ااا يعني في
المصري بعنوان لنور الشريف اخر الرجال
المحترمين يصحوا للحقيقه على طارق البيطار
هذا الوصف فهو من اخر الرجال المحترمين
الذين يريدون الوصول
بان عودته بقرار
ااه عودته بقرار مستند الى القانون اولا
كما يعني فهمنا من خلفيه هذه العوده
الخلفيه القانونيه ليس هناك اي نص قانوني
يكف او يكف يد او يرد القاضي طارق البيطار
الامر الثاني ان قوه القضيه التي يحقق
فيها هي من قوه المحقق العدل وبالتالي اذا
اقصي المحقق العدل بطريقه غير قانونيه فان
هذه القضيه مهدده بان توضع في الادراج
الامر الثالث يحق بموجب القانون للقاضي
طارق البيطار استدعاء اي كان وفقا شبهات
همم معززه بادله وبنعطيات لديه استدعاء اي
كان وكانه
ما الذي اختلف حتى قام القاضي البيطار
بهذه الخطوات توفر معلومات ام هناك دوافع
اخرى
هذا السؤال هو الجواب هو عند القاضي طارق
البيطار الذي يحيط الملف السريه وهذا حقه
وهذا واجبه ايضا هو
اللي يبقى التوقف عند طول المده التي توقف
بها وعودته الان وسر هذا التوقيت هذا امر
تفاصيل
برايي تصغر عند عظم هذا الملف الواضح ان
هذا القاضي مصر على تحقيق العداله وعلى
المضيق قدما وعلى غرق غرق هذا الجدار
السمين الذي وضع بوجهه
بتحالف من مافيا سياسيه للاسف مافيا كبيره
تريد اعاقه التحقيق ومنع الوصول الى
العداله والتنميه الازرق
فتح التحقيق من جديد هل هناك شيء ترى بعض
ردود الفعل الاوليه ربطت بين هذه الخطوه و
اتصالي بمحققين فرنسيين هم ايضا يقومون
بالتحقيق ما يتعلق بفرنسيين قتلوا اثناء
تفجير تفجيراته
استاذ عبد القادر حقيقه سؤال الكبير ان
الذي قرر ان يلتزم بموجبات الاستبعاد عن
الملف سنه وثلاثه اشهر وقرر الان هو بنفسه
الاعتماد على دراسات للعوده واضح تماما
انه تجاوز وزير العدل كسلطه وصايه تجاوز
مدعي عام التمييز كسلطه هي التي ستبادر
الى التوقيفات او الاختلافات الاعتقالات
او الاخلاءات اما التوقيت السياسي واضح
تماما ان اجتماعه بالقضاه الفرنسيين يجعله
بالقلفي يستند الى ما يسمى القضاء الدولي
او القانون الدولي ومعروف ان مجيء
المحققين الاجانب بقضيه رياض سلامه قد
يكون فتح شهيته على المخاطره علما ان
التوقيت واضح تماما انه يستفيد من عوامل
جانبيه يعيش البلد باكثر من ملف ويسعى من
خلاله هو لفتح دفر سوار يستطيع من خلاله
ان يتجاوز جميع السلطات في المناسبه بمجلس
القضاء الاعلى كسلطه عليا غدا سينظر في
قانونيه ما قام به القاضي بيطار ويبقى على
مجلس الوزراء ان يقرر وهو الذي عين القاضي
بيطار الموقف الرسمي
وكذلك اسعد بشاره الكاتب الصحفي
[موسيقى]
نظم اعضاء من حزب اللكود الاسرائيلي
ومنظمات يمنيه متطرفات تجمعان عند مشارك
في الخان الاحمر شرقي القدس المحتله للضغط
على الحكومه لتسريع تنفيذ قرار هدم التجمع
في المقابل تظهر عشرات الفلسطينيين
الاجانب للمطالبه بمنع تنفيذ القرار و
بعدم تهجير سكان التجمع قصرا وتلتئم
المحكمه الاسرائيليه العليا الشهر المقبل
للنظر في طلب منظمه
الصهيونيه
لتنفيذي عمليه الهدم
من تله مشرفه على تجمع الخان الاحمر شرقي
القدس المحتله اطل اعضاء من حزب اللكود
واليامين الاسرائيلي المتطرف خطوه يرى
فلسطينيون انها تهدف الى دفع محكمه العدل
العليا الاسرائيليه الى اتخاذ قرار
النهائي بهدف التجمع والضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من اجل تنفيذه
فلسطينيين
مسانده لسكان الخان الاحمر
ارتفعت هنا
مطالبين بقطع الطريق على مخططات الاحتلال
التوسعيه ان الشعب الفلسطيني سيبقى صامد
وذهب كل طغاه العالم كل طغاه هذا الاجرام
الصهيوني الى مزابل التاريخ من شارون والى
اخره وبقي الشعب الفلسطيني وسيذهب ايضا
الى مزابل التاريخ وسيبقى هذا العلم
الفلسطيني يرفرف فوق الاراضي الفلسطينيه
سكان التجمع الذين يدركون خطورته هذه
التهديدات الاسرائيليه يستاندون كما
يقولون في صمودهم على التضامن الشعبي
والدولي مع قضيتهم احنا هناك باذن الله عز
وجل صامدين على هذه الارض ولم نرحل وسن
وقام بكل من قوه هذا ارضنا واحنا موجودين
على ارضنا ولا نعيش نقله ثانيه لان الشعب
الفلسطيني
ويضم الخان الاحمر 35 عائله مكونه من نحو
240 شخصا ويعيشون على الثروه الحيوانيه
كما تحيط بالتجمع مستوطنات كبيره باتت
تسارع في توسعها نحو التجمع ومحيطه ما
يهدد الوجود الفلسطينيه في المنطقه
بين مساء اليمين الاسرائيلي المتطرف للضغط
على الحكومه لهدم لهذا التجمع البدويه
واصرار الفلسطينيين على منعه تبقى قضيه
الخان الاحمر وقودا لخلاف اضافي داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه واختبارا لها امام
المجتمع الدوليه الرافضي لهذا القرار سمير
ابو شمالي الجزيره من تجمع الخان الاحمر
البدويه شرقيه القدس المحتله
يقع تجمع الخامس بين القدس المحتله واريحا
حيث ينتشر اكثر من 25 تجمعا بدويا وتهدف
اسرائيل من ازالته الى قطع التواصل بين
شمال الضفه وجنوبها والقضاء على امكانيه
قيام الدوله الفلسطينيه وذلك بتشريد
عائلات في القدس ومحيطها لتخفيض نسبه
الفلسطينيين لصالح التوسع الاستيطاني
اضافه الى اكمال مخطط اي وان شرق القدس
لربطه المدينه بمستوطنات الاحتلال في
مناطق الضفه الغربيه المحتله لا سيما
مستوطنه معالي ادومي
وقال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بريتارياهو
ان الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه ازالت منذ
بدايه الشهر الحالي ثمانيه وثلاثين مبنا
غير قانوني شيدها الفلسطينيون في الضفه
الغربيه حسب تعبيره واضاف نتنياهو في
تغريد ان الوضع السابق الذي حاول فيه
الفلسطينيون فرض امر واقع من خلال البناء
غير المرخص في الضفه الغربيه قد انتهى
وقد اعلن مفوضوا السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوري لانه سيلتقي
رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني للبحث في عدد من
قضايا الملف الفلسطيني واضاف بوريل في
بيان انه سيناقش مع رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني الوضع على الارض الذي اصبح
مقلقا للغايه على حد وصفه البيان
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا وفيها ابقى وزير العمل الباب
مفتوح عن امام التبني اي تعديلات قد
يدخلها البرلمان على نص مشروع اصلاح نظام
التقاعد شرطه الا اتمسى على حد قوله
بالاسس التي ينبني عليها مشروع الاصلاح او
بهدف اعاده التوازن لنظام التقاعدي في
افقع عام 2030
طب خليجي
احكام المسبقه بشان النقاشات في البرلمان
فالتعديلات لم تطرح بعد سيتم ذلك مساء
الخميس امام اللجنه المختصه لتطرح بعد ذلك
للفحص في الجلسه لكن اذا مقترحت اي
تعديلات بامكانها تحسين النص من دون
التخلي عن هدف بلوغ التوازن المالي لنظام
التقاعد في افق عام 2030 ولا عن الاسس
التي يقوم عليها مشروع الاصلاح فسنكون
طبعا منفتحين عليها
ردت حكومه بوركينا فاسو على طلب الرئيس
الفرنسي ايضاحات بشان قرارها انهاء
التعاون العسكريين مع فرنسا وقال الناطق
باسم الحكومه ان سلطات بلاده لا يمكن ان
تقدمه ايضاحات اكثر مما قدمت مضيفا ان
الانسحاب الفرنسي لن يخلف اي فراغ وفق
تعبيري
الذي فيزيون
رؤيتنا للمرحله الانتقاليه هي ان اهل
بوركينا فاسو انفسهم سيقدمون التضحيات من
اجل تحرير بلدنا واستعاده اسيادته
الاقليميه واعاده تاسيس البلدي كذلك هذه
هي الرؤيه التي تحملها سلطات بوركينا فاسو
حاليا
واردنا على استفسار بقناه الجزيره قال
مصدرا دبلوماسي في سفاره باريس في بوركينا
فاسو تلقت مذكره شفهيه وان الرئيس قال في
تصريح السابق ان فرنسا تنتظرون من رئيس
المرحله الانتقاليه في بوركينا فاسو توضيح
هذه المذكره واوضح المصدر ان باريس
وبالتشاور مع شركائها ستعيدو تكييفا
وجودها العسكري في منطقه الساحل لتظل الى
جانب البلدان المنخرطه في مكافحه الارهاب
نقلت الوكاله العامه لاداره القضاء
العسكري في تونس وجودا اي خلل في
الاجراءات القانونيه لمحاكمه المتهمين
فيما تعرفوا بقضيه المطار في اشاره الى
نواب ائتلاف الكرامه في البرلمان المنحل
واكدت الوكاله العامله في بيان ان اجراءات
المحكمه العسكريه سليمه من الناحيه
القانونيه داعيه الى احترام الاحكام
القضائيه وعلويه القانون والناي بالقضاء
العسكري عن جميع انواع التجابات خصوصا ان
بعد الطعن في الاحكام الصادره مازال قائما
وفق تعابير البيان
اينما قال مصطفى هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه
المعزولين التونسي العياش الهمامي ان عدد
من المحامين رفع دعوى قضائي ضد وزيره
العدل على خلفيه ما وصفه بجريمه عدم
تطبيقها لاحكام المحكمه الاداريه التي قضت
بايقاف تنفيذ قرار عزل 37 قاضيا كما عبرت
هيئه المحامين عن رفضها للاحكام الصادره
من القضاء العسكري ضد محاميين فيما تعرف
بقضيه المطار وتاتي هذه التطورات في
السياق ازمه الحاده بين السلطه التنفيذيه
واجهزه القضاء في تونس
جنى حال عدالتي في تونس في معركه ضد
السلطه ما زال ملف القضاه المعزولين يراوح
مكانه الى اليوم رغم مروري اكثر من خمسه
اشهر على قرار المحكمه الاداريه ايقافه
تنفيذي عزل عدد منهم هيئه الدفاع تصف
القرار بالجريمه التي استوجبت تقديم شكاوى
ضد وزيره العدل
الجزائريه ونطلب من النيابه العموميه كما
كانت سريعه في حاله المحامين في 24 ساعه
بتعليمات من وزيره العدل على التحقيق نطلب
من النيابه العموميه ان تسرع في السماع
الى المشتكى بها والى الشكين
[تصفيق]
غير بعيد يرفع المحامون صوتهم عاليا ضد
محاكمه القضاء العسكري لزملائهم سجن
المحاميين مهدي زقروبه وسيف الدين مخلوف
على خلفيه الاحكام الصادره ضدهما فيما
يعرف بقضيه المطار ترى فيه عماده المحامين
استهدافا ممهجا لقطاع المحاماه
العسكريه ويتوقف عليها نحن نرفض هذه
المحاكمات للمدنين ونرفض ان يتم تنفيذ هذه
القرارات في ساعه في ساعه زمان
بما يوحي ان هناك استهداف للاطفال
رئيس قيس سعيد منذ توليه السلطه في البلاد
حرسه على ما يصفه بتطهير القضاء وهو يرى
في ذلك مفتاحا لحل جميع ازمات البلاد هذه
العلاقه المتوتره بين سعيد والقضاء ترجمت
الى قرارات الرئاسيه وصفها كثيرون
بالمزلزله ليس اقلها حل المجلس الاعلى
للقضاء وعزل اكثر من 50 قاضيا في ملف
تتواصلوا تداعياته الى اليوم الى الازمات
السياسيه والاجتماعيه المتفاقمه تضاف ازمه
اخرى تشمل مرفق العداله هذه المره ازمه
جعلت ميزان العداله يتارجح بين طرف حجته
الدفاع عن استقلاليه القضاء واخرى يتمسك
بما يراه مشروعا لانفاذ القانونه ميساء
الفت ناسي الجزيره تونس
[موسيقى]
عوده الى المناورات العسكريه المشتركه بين
روسيا والصين وجنوب افريقيا المقرره الشهر
المقبل تزامنا مع ذكر الاولى
روسيا على اوكرانيا التدريبات ستكون بحريه
قرب مدينتي
على الساحلي الشرقي لجنوب افريقيا وتستمر
10 ايام اي من السابعه عشر وحتى السابع
والعشرين من فبراير المقبل وتشارك في هذه
المناورات الروسيه الادمره التي تحمل
صواريخ فرصيه من نوعه تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت 9 مرات ويبلغ مداها اكثر من 1000
كلم
جنوب افريقيا والصين وروسيا الى جانب
البرازيل والهند تحت ما يعرف بتحالف بريكس
وهو تكتل تاسس عام
1909 ويجمعوا الدول صاحبه اسرع نمو
اقتصادي في العالم وتقول جنوب افريقيا ان
هدف المناورات هو تعزيز العلاقات بين
الدول الثلاث وتاكيد موقفي بريتوريا
المستقلي بعيدا عن الاصطفافات التي املتها
الحرب في اوكرانيا
هذه المناورات المحمله بالرسائل ليست
الاولى التي يشارك فيها الجيش الروسي قبل
واثناء حربه على اوكرانيا فقد شارك عام
2019 في تدريبات بحريه هي الاولى مع جيشي
جنوب افريقيا والصين قبالتها سواحل
في سبتمبر الماضي استضافت روسيا مناورات
عسكريه واسعه النطاق في اقصى شرق البلاد
شاركت فيها عده دول بينها الصين والهند
بالروسيا وفي اواخر ديسمبر الماضي اجره
روسيا والصين مناورات بحريه قرب مضيق وصفت
بالاكبر في التاريخ
وقبل نحوي اسبوعين اجره الفرقاطه جرش كوف
تمرينات في بحره النرويج قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انها لصدمه جويا محتمل في
ظروف مائيه معقده
ورحب بضيفي لبحث هذا الملف وهذه الحسابات
الروسيه خاصه المتعلقه منها بافريقيا
استقبل ضيف من تورنتو عبد القادر محمد علي
الباحث المختص في شان الافريقي سيد عبد
القادر كيف وجدت هذه الحسابات الروسيه
فيما يتعلق بافريقيا
الحقيقه ان هذه المناورات المشتركه هي حتى
مظهرات الدوله الروسيه المتناميه في
القاره الافريقيه والاسيه في افريقيا
مسبقه بجوله جديده لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الى القاره الافريقيه وبالمناسبه هذه هي
الدوله الثالثه خلال تقريبا سبعه او
ثمانيه اشهر ما يعني يبرز الاهميه التي
تليها موسكو للقاره الافريقيه الحقيقه انه
هناك العديد من العناوين التي يمكن ان
يقرا تحتها هذه النوع من النشاط سواء كانت
الدبلوماسي او العسكري لعل من اهم منها
تصدير رساله الى الداخل الروسي والى خارج
الروسي ان روسيا ليست معزوله وان لديها
اصدقاء في مناطق مختلفه من العالم وانها
قادره على صنع اصطفافات همم في عالم تصوير
وعاده على انه عالم يلد النظام المتعدد
الاقطاب
هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى ايضا
هو تعزيز للحضور الروسي العسكري في القاره
الافريقيه والذي
تجلى في العديد من المناطق والعديد من
المستويات روسيا الان هي اكبر مصدر للسلاح
للقاره الافريقيه روسيا الان دخلت في
معاهدات اكثر من 20 دوله افريقيه معاهدات
تتضمن التعاون الامني والتدريب العسكري
الى غير ذلك من الشؤون الامنيه والعسكريه
الجانب العسكري الامني هو همم ابرز نشاطات
روسيا في القاره الافريقيه في الحقيقه
وهذا يعود لمجموعه من العوامل العلم الاهم
بها انها لا تستطيع منافسه الحضور الصيني
القوي النظر الى
الصينيه الماليه الكبيره او الملائه
الكبيره الاتحاد الاوروبي او حتى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
بجانب ذلك ايضا هناك ضعفي ما يسمى بالقوه
الناعمه الروسيه في افريقيا لانه ليس هناك
نموذج حقيقي ملهم بالنسبه للدول الافريقيه
من الممكن ان تصدره روسيا ولذلك
يميل الارقام العسكريه في افريقيا
لسؤال سيد عبد القادر عندما نقول عن
مناورات من ضمنها الجنوب افريقيا تشارك
فيها فرقه بحجم الادمره
الروسيه في افريقيا هناك ايضا النشاط
واتمدد في دول الساحل والصحراء مالي والان
بوركينا فاسو تحركات في دول اخرى ما طبيعه
هذه الحسابات
الحسابات الروسيه في افريقيا عموما مرتبطه
بالعامل الاقتصادي حيث تذكرت ورقه صادره
من معهد الدراسات الافريقيه في موسكو ان
القاره الافريقيه تحتوي على العديد من
المواد الاوليه التي تحتاج اليها روسيا من
جانب اخر ايضا تمثل افريقيا سوقها كبيره
لتصدير البضاعه الروسيه بالنسبه لمثل هذه
المناورات او التحركات الروسيه هناك ورقه
اخرى ايضا اكدت على وجود اربع دول رئيسيه
في القاره الافريقيه ينبغي ان تعزز موسكو
علاقاتها معها هي نيجيريا واثيوبيا ونصر
وجنوب افريقيا التي يزورها الان اا سبيل
الله ايضا اكدت على وجود مجموعه من
المناطق الهامه التي ينبغي على روسيا
تعزيز وجودها فيها من هذه المناطق اقليم
البحر الاحمر همم بشكل كامل المخلوط
الافريقي في جنوب افريقيا كذلك جنوب البحر
المتوسط ومنطقه الساحل
تعزيز روسيا لحضور في هذه المناطق يحمل
العديد من المعاني كما ذكرت همم المعنى
الاقتصادي والمعنى المتعلق بالنفوذ
والسياسي
وتحدي النفوذ الغربي الراسخ في بعض
المناطق مثلا في منطقه الساحل ااه هناك
صراع فرنسي روسيا على همم
استقطاب اكبر عدد ممكن من الدول هناك هناك
محاوله روسيه للاستفاده من التيار الشعب
عام موجود الان في منطقه غرب افريقيا
معادله فرنسا هناك نشاط روسي كبير جدا
سيفراني يخترق
ويحاول ترويج شكرا الافريقي
[موسيقى]
ملايين الاشخاص بلا كهرباء يحدث ذلك في
مدن باكستانيه كبرى من بينها اسلام اباد
ويشمل قطاعات حيويه مختلفه ومشهد المتكرر
لكنه اعتبر اليوم الاسود في تاريخ باكستان
اتحدث عن بلد يقدر عدده سكانه بنحويه 220
مليون ويواجه ازمه طاقه منذ سنوات يستمر
الانقطاع ساعات ثم تعود الامور الى
طبيعتها وامر المزعج يذكر النبي
يعيشون بالفعل بلا كهرباء ولا يحصلون على
اضاءه الا من مصادر ضلت البشريه تعتمد
عليها منذ فجر التاريخ مثل حطب الاشجار
والفحم النباتي او مخلفات الحيوانات وهي
مصادر تتسبب في تلويث البيئه وكذلك وفاه
الملايين والامل كل الامل ان ينجح العالم
في الق على ظاهره تسمى فكر الطاقه وهي تحد
تنموي ضخم شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]